شهدائنا مش ارقام الدوله لازم يندفنوا في
مقابر المسلمين في فلسطين لا توجد دوله في
العالم ولا حتى عصابه تحتجس جثامين وتساوي
عليها من بينهم 12 طفلا ومن بينهم نساء
جثامينهم محتجازه في الثلاجات
[موسيقى]
قبر مفتوح لكن ابني موجود في مكان اخر
وابني اسير اسير شهيد
حتى منطقه امنيه
هل تلقيتم ايه وعود بالضغط على اسرائيل
كلها وعوده وعوده من السلطه من غير السلطه
احنا رفعنا للمحكمه العليا للجنايات لغير
الغيراته كلها وعيد اقسم بالله العظيم انا
التلاجه اللي في الدار ما بفتحها كل ما
حدا
مرتاح بدك اكثر من المعاني
وانا حتى صار عندي شك انه شادي ما استشهد
لانه ما اجانا اي خبر يقين من قبل
الاحتلال او من قبل اي مؤسسه رسميه انه
شادي استشهد
هذه القضيه تحديدا عندما تكون الاسره لا
تعرف ما حدث لابنها هذه الامور هي تعتبر
وحشيه وتتخطى حتى ما بامكان العقل ان
يتصور الطريقه التي نراها هي تعتبر انتهاك
لحقوق الموتى ما الذي تقوله الاحصائيات
لديكم في ما يخص هذه القضيه
الموثق الحالات الموثقه هم
شهيدا اضافه الى
76 مفقوده
[موسيقى]
في بعض الحالات التي يتم تحرير فيها تحرير
تضع سلطات الاحتلال شرطا بمنع اجراء
التشريح عدلي وتستوفي كفالات من اهالي
الشهداء في حال
ابنائهم لماذا لا يريدون التشريح اي جرائم
يخونها
قوات الاحتلال امام مسؤوليات هادي الامر
هو صعب للغايه في الوقت الذي تتمتع فيه
اسرائيل
بالدعم الكامل للقوى العظمى هذه المساله
هي محبطه بالنسبه للفلسطينيين لانهم لا
يرون اي افقع في يوم ما سوف تنتصر عظام
الشهداء واشلاهم على هذه الغطرسه